merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture monsieur le ministre
notre agriculture traverse une crise
profonde
quels que soient les secteurs d'activité
ça a été répétée par mon collègue marc
lefur tout à l'heure la situation est
tendue
beaucoup d'exploitations ne dispose plus
du tout trésorerie et non plus aucune
marge
parmi toutes ces filières je souhaite
m'attarder plus précisément cet
après-midi sur la filière avicole touché
de plein fouet par le virus h5n1
sans parler des gesticulations autour de
l'épisode pamela anderson qui exaspère
encore un peu plus nos éleveurs au
moment où ils n'en n'ont vraiment pas
besoin pour éradiquer le virus
vous avez défini une stratégie sans
doute à juste titre qu'ils imposent à
compter du 18 janvier des vides
sanitaires sur tout le sud-ouest ce sont
dix-huit départements qui sont touchés
les accouveurs sur le premier maillon de
la chaîne d'élevage ce sont donc les
premiers impactés par cette mesure
le préjudice est énorme entre 30 et 35
millions d'euros puisque les accouveurs
doivent continuer d'entretenir les
animaux reproducteurs alors qu'il leur
sera impossible d'écouler leur
production pendant au moins six mois ils
doivent néanmoins nourrir ce cheptel
pour réapprovisionner les éleveurs
dès la reprise de l'activité la filière
a chiffré les pertes financières
globales à 300 millions d'euros en plus
des accouveurs elles concerneront tous
les emplois directs qui dépendent de la
filière comme les éleveurs bien sûr les
abattoirs les entreprises de
transformation mais aussi les emplois
indirects comme les entreprises de
transport de production d'aliments ou
encore les restaurateurs les
professionnels de la filière attendent
de votre part un geste fort pour cette
crise totalement indépendante des cours
cette fois ci aussi monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous aujourd'hui annoncé que des
aides ont été fléchés afin de venir au
secours de toute une filière gravement
menacée et qu'elle monte en avez vous
prévu d'attribuer notamment à la filière
de la couv âge la parole est à monsieur
stéphane le foll mini d'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
ce président est monsieur le député vous
avez évoqué globalement la crise delà
des filières d'élevage et vous avez posé
une question sur ce que vit une filière
avicole et palmipèdes au travers je le
rappelle d'un virus parce que le h5n1 et
voir avec des mutations h 59
c'est un virus et les décisions que j'ai
prises monsieur le député elles sont mus
par une seule motivation éviter que
toute la filière pâtissent de la
pérennisation de ce virus qui remet en
cause le statut eynden de la france et
qui doit nécessiter donc des mesures à
la hauteur de l'enjeu économique et
social vous avez posé une question est
ce que nous avons mis en place un plan
pour venir en aide suite aux décisions
qui ont été prises à toute cette filière
ce matin pendant deux heures avec
l'ensemble de la filière et le président
du cifog nous avons eu des discussions
pour justement peaufiner et les mesures
sanitaires qui seront mises en oeuvre et
les mesures financières pour venir aider
les éleveurs et en particulier les
accouveurs c'est vrai que cette mesure
de vide sanitaire
on l'a choisi et je les choisis pour
éviter les foyers et les abattages
massifs d'animaux je pense que c'est
mieux pour l'ensemble de cette vie hier
et en terme d'image et en termes
d'efficacité
cette mise en oeuvre se fera avec les
premiers touchés c'est à dire ceux qui
ont été touchés par les foyers dès la
fin de l'année dernière et les
accouveurs qui sont en début de chaîne
puisque c'est eux qui fournissent les
poussins et les canetons pour pouvoir
remettre en production c 130 millions
dead qui ont été ce matin discuter mise
sur la table par le gouvernement avec
une priorité les accouveurs et les
éleveurs s'ajoutera à ces aides
d'autres aides pour les entreprises
parce que c'est une filière dans sa
globalité qui est touchée par cette
crise d'affluence ya aviaire merci la
parole est un monsieur meyer habib
merci